[Musik]
herzlich kommt zurück sagt leute ich
mich wieder für euch da mit einer neuen
hilft mir action und ich kann euch schon
mal so viel sagen leute diese folge die
wir uns heute zusammen anschauen
die wird wirklich auch im vergleich zu
allen anderen folgen die wir schon
gesehen haben sehr schwer für uns aber
bevor wir anfangen heute eine runde
applaus für die ersten gewinner des 50
euro erscheint zwar ist das oder
versorgung gewinner ich weiß es nicht es
ist der account coruxo der waren zu der
hilfe folge mit dem priester unter den
ersten zwanzig kommentaren und hat mit
hey und einem like den 50 euro gutschein
gewonnen
falls du der besitzer von vertrauen ist
entscheidend auf instagram escape mit
einem foto auf dem man sieht dass du den
account eingeloggt ist und dann kriegst
du den code für den gutschein von mir
soviel dazu leute und jetzt warten wir
haben mit der hilfe folge oh mein gott
ich habe mich verliebt in den sohn der
asi nachbarn und mamma mia sind die
nachbarn nach sich
[Musik]
so brauchen wir gar nicht war okay so
ist es möglich anfang okay ich bin
gerade mal sechs gründliches wir in
sechs sekunden und somit die muss ich
anschauen weil ich bin sowas von so was
machen sie denn hier wohl aussichtslos
wir können schon mal so viel sagen leute
der titel hat uns möglicherweise nicht
angelogen wenn an dieser stelle die rede
von asi nachbarn ist dann ist das muss
ich wirklich ehrlich sagen gelinde
gesagt eine untertreibung
nähert man sich den hausflur und wir
sehen sie denn überhaupt ja ich bin der
neue nachbar müller mein name tut mir
leid dass du jetzt nicht so hin zu
drehen kann aber sie können sich sicher
vorstellen das ist jetzt gerade nicht so
ganz einfach genau was ich sagen wollte
wollen sie fragt am sonntag vorbei
kommen wir trinken runde kaffee zusammen
wir machen das hier rauskommen und zwar
schnell also ich muss sagen ich stehe
schon wieder hier in meinem zimmer und
erneut fällt es mir schwer zu glauben
was ich gerade sehe was meine augen
gerade sehen dass das eine das eine
produktion eines deutschen fernsehteams
auf deutschem boden ist aber es ist so
also die ganze sache jetzt schon relativ
hoffnungslos leute aber ein kleiner
funken hoffnung schimmert am horizont
diese frau die wahrscheinlich die frau
von dem typen ist er da gerade ins
treppenhaus
sie kommt jetzt aus der wohnung aus okay
bitte bitte zeit irgendeine reaktion die
ausdruck dass du es nicht okay findet
was down under macht
ihr mann entleert sich hier im hausflur
auch haase hat es wieder nicht bis nach
hause geschafft also ok also die frau
kommt aus der wohnung raus der mann
steht im treppenhaus hat ich will ja
nicht nein ich beschreibe die sich jetzt
nicht weiter das ist ein scheiß alter
nicht unserer schon ach so hat das ist
nicht jemand macht es also sehr und
deswegen und soll ich mir gerade
vorzustellen wie ich reagieren würde
wenn wir das mit mir das passieren würde
wenn ich im treppenhaus auf so eine
haarsträubende situationen treffen würde
ich glaube entweder ich will einfach
vorbeigehen wie es kann eben schon
gesagt am anfang gar nicht reagiert oder
ich würde die leute so zusammenhalten
als unwahrscheinlich dass in meinem
treppenhaus
wenn du da so was will man rechne damit
dass sich die treppe runter schneit
deswegen steht dies hier neuerdings soja
im hausflur werden
jetzt mache ich hätte was machst du
ne ne ne ne ne ne
der stopp stopp ohne witz dass das auch
das ist nicht mehr witzig ok hilfe das
ist nicht mehr wenn sie ernsthaft
stellen auch zu ihm spaß und euch die
fragen so ja was macht ihr so was soll
das ich mein land viel seltsame sachen
hoch aber das hier was diese frauen
gerade gesagt hat überschreitet wirklich
eine grenze ok ohne wissen denn das
würde ich wirklich nicht auf youtube
sind also sorry
wo sind wir denn hier bitte solche
nachbarn wünscht sich niemand und so ein
verhalten muss man sich nicht gefallen
lassen
am besten wendet man sich in solchen
fällen an die hausverwaltung rest in
peace auch an die hilfen experten die ja
quasi das gleiche schicksal ereilt hat
wie mich dass sie sich diese folgen
anschauen dann irgendwas zu sagen müssen
dass die können sich nicht mehr darüber
lustig machen die müssen dann irgendwas
ernsthaftes dazu sagen dazu ja also ja
solche nachbarn wünscht sich wirklich
keiner no shit
[Musik]
also
das sind doch wirklich ist drin ich
komme nicht drauf klar wie relax diese
darstellerin damit umgehen das geht
nicht klar
also sorry bei aller liebe auch allein
das eigentlich schon auch so der satz
das sind aber es tut dem was gerade in
dieser folge passiert ist wirklich nicht
genüge angemessen wenn die szene in der
sie zum beispiel am pc sitzt und sowas
gut wie stelle ich meine verlorene ehre
wieder her
in welches land soll ich ihn jetzt wo
ich deutschland verlassen muss was
bedeutet das für die besten dem man so
sagen sie ja früher war alles besser
damals noch ohne internet es war so geil
wenn ich irgendwas wissen sollte ich
konnte es einfach nicht sofort erfahren
wie geil ist das oder ich wusste in der
bibliothek rennen oder mir zig meter an
enzyklopädien an lexika in die
bücherregale stellten achten geld dafür
bezahlen
wie war das denn nochmal ganz verstanden
eine heile welt bricht zusammen und bald
wird das nämlich eine ganz gefährliche
gegend werden auch weiter nicht
übertreibt maßlos könnt ihr bitte dieser
frau mal zur seite stehen habt ihr habt
noch mitbekommen was passiert ist aber
sie hat es euch doch erzählt wie kann
man noch ein fuß still halten danach ich
hoffe das war auch kurz gesehen aber
freundlich begrüßt
man dachte warum hasst nichts davon
erzählt nicht dass es wichtig ist was
die nachbarn freundlich gegrüßt warum
sagst du wer ständig vorn dann ist doch
alles wieder gut ganz davon abgesehen
wird auch gern mal den vermieter sehen
der diese nahm sie nachbarn eine wohnung
gibt so wie soll das denn aussehen soll
also die kommen zum besichtigungstermin
wahrscheinlich komplett nach begrüßen
den vermieter mit natur und der
vermieter so wissen sie was sie haben
die wohnung
[Musik]
sorry aber ohne wirtsleute wirklich
wirklich wirklich wirklich wirklich
jetzt real tag der punkt an dem diese
folge die grenze von ok alles lustig zu
das ist jetzt wirklich too much
überschritten hat der liegt schon lange
in der vergangenheit erlebt was passiert
jetzt die frau hat scheinbar aus dem
keller oder so weil die wohnung auf
einer ebene
sie kommt von unten nach oben also hat
sie scheinbar aus dem keller oder von
der straße müllsäcke geholt die nicht
mal ihre eigenen sind was macht sie
damit geht er mir zur nachbarin lehrt
die aus einfach abschieben kleine besser
aber okay jetzt mal ganz gut sehen so
wer verliebt sich jetzt in wien
[Musik]
verliebt so schnell geht's aber das team
ist version von den nachbarn die unser
komplettes haus terrorisieren
also es gab verlegt natürlich so hole
wird ich fühle mich wirklich beleidigt
von dieser folge diese folge beleidigt
mich sonst aber schon ja oder ja geil
ich auch können wir noch ein paar
minuten quatschen dann bist du von denen
die hier neu eingezogen und sie in die
hand nein einfach nein also ich bin
nicht dafür dass man kinder für das foto
was ihre eltern machen aber muss man
auch mal klare kante zeigen also dieses
verhaltens wir gesehen haben ist
wirklich ein verbrechen gegen die
menschlichkeit okay
und da kann man auch nicht mit
irgendwelchen wir springen müssen weiter
leute leider ist das tragische wirklich
geschehen und die beiden sind in
irgendeiner form zusammengekommen
aufgeschlossen da bin ich direkt
verfallen was kann ich meine eltern oder
durch vereine auch das interessante
eigentlich sollte aus der asi familie
kommt rät dazu ganz normal so ja ok wie
heißt du ich bin der und der umwelt so
ein quatsch ich werde deine eltern sind
schon okay ich wäre ja wenn dagegen
nicht unbedingt ich muss das nicht
wirklich sagen leute
sorry das ist diese folge gibt ich habe
sie zwar nicht produziert aber es tut
mir wirklich leid
das ist jedenfalls war mir doch ihr
kriegt ihr doch immerhin für euch
vorgeschlagen das video hier oben könnte
meinen kanal abonnieren bleibt haften
bleibt stark in zwei tagen gibt es ein
neues video von mir